hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled a crispr-powered
universal infectious disease assay this
webinar is part of the 2021 microbiology
virtual event and i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and sponsored by jump code genomics for
more information about jump code
genomics go to www.jumpcodegenomics
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen now as a
reminder the presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
of right hand corner of your screen and
follow the process to obtain those
credits without further ado i now
present today's speaker john armstrong
the vice president of research
development at jump code genomics for a
complete biography of our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen john welcome you may
now begin hello my name is john
armstrong i'm the vice president of of r
d for jump code genomics and i'm
really happy to be here today to talk
with you about a
assay we've been working on for the last
year or so that leverages crispr and
really uses crispr as an engine
for a universal infectious disease assay
so
within the realm of next gen next gen
next gen sequencing and even metagenomic
shotgun sequencing one of the classic
and historic problems is this needle in
the haystack where
you know the things that you're looking
for but
most of the molecules in the samples are
uninformative and ultimately they mask
the signal that you're looking for and
so we've been
working diligently on a solution for
this called the crispr clean technology
and i'll tell you a little bit more
about how that works in the next couple
slides but ultimately it enables
scientists to focus on the signal and uh
and not the noise
so
essentially uh this is one way that that
our crispr clean technology can be
employed
where
the it seamlessly integrates into the
ngs workflow where you have a sample
prep
and then with that sample prep
you end up generating an ngs library and
then the crispr clean technology can
then be employed at the end of the
library prep to reduce the number of
molecules that would be sequenced from
non-informative areas
and then ultimately as i just mentioned
you have the sequencing component
the the technology works to increase
sensitivity of detection it's unbiased
in the way that it works it's a simple
four hour total time workflow hands-on
time is around one and a half to two
hours and we see really efficient
depletion of the of the regions
or genes or
um
fragments that we're targeting and at
the end of the day it allows it allows
researchers to access lower input
amounts and sample types then you might
have been able to previously do with it
with a depletion technology that happens
up front and works to reduce your total
rna amount
and so this is how crispr clean works so
ultimately we use uh cass 9 and guide
rnas we design guide rnas
to
target the
areas or
of the genome or the transcriptome that
we don't want to end up taking up real
estate on the flow cell or this
sequencing machine we can use cas9 and
guide rnas complexed in an rnp
and then digest those library fragments
that the guide rnas are designed to
once those
once those fragments are digested
then a simple pcr amplification is is
uh is used and since those fragments now
since the adapters that are ligated on
the ends of those fragments in the ngs
library construction process
since now those fragments are in two
pieces
uh no pcr product can be formed from
those fragments and we end up with a
high material that's highly enriched for
the areas that are informative
and uh are in the material has been
depleted of the areas that are
non-informative and i'll show you data
from that
as we move through the talk today
and so 2021 for us has been a focus on
rna products we have a product for
transcriptomic
analysis would be bulk rna sequencing we
have one for microbiome meta
transcriptomics and i'll show you some
early proof of concept data that we
generated
using the metatranscriptomics kit
we have a single cell analysis product
as well and then finally the one i'm
going to be talking about today is our
infectious disease surveillance product
and kit for that assay
so on the left here there's a lot of
words i understand
you can find all of this on our website
of course let me give you the take home
the take home here is that in
metagenomic samples things like
nasopharyngeal samples saliva samples
fecal samples or even microbiome samples
this is a complex sample that's going to
contain a mixture of bacterial and human
cells and
bacterial and human ribosomal rna and
total rna or i mean are the rna species
as well as viral rna and fungal rna and
so these are complex samples
those complex samples and the complexity
of that
means that really you have a needle in
the haystack problem when we
when we
use the crisper clean technology to
deplete and effectively eliminate the
bacterial and human ribosomal rna from
these samples we essentially facilitate
the identification of lower express
transcripts and biologically relevant
transcripts
and so the um the meta transcriptomic
kit that i'll show some proof of concept
data from is uh was uh and also our um
crispr cream crisper clean plus kit that
i'll show data at the end of the talk
is designed towards human ribosomal rna
species that are listed here in the
table on the right
and to
the
sum or the superset of ribosomal species
across 200 plus bacteria
and
if
we have a recommended library type for
for post pcr depletion using the neb
next ultra two directional rna kit
but also in october we'll be releasing a
full solution that bundles together the
depletion reagents with an rna library
kit as well
and so here's the workflow for that
bundled solution it's uh will be the uh
crispr clean stranded total rna prep
with ribosomal depletion and or crispr
clean plus in the case of of of
metagenomics or uh universal infectious
disease uh detection where we're putting
the depletion of the ribosomal rna
instead of after the library process
we're actually depleting
fragments that originated from ribosomal
rna
between the adapter ligation and final
pcr amplification it's really seamless
integration makes the library prep
extremely easy
the hands-on time total is only one and
a half hours for this additional step
and really allows a competent tech to be
able to move
through the library process and
depletion with numerous sample types
within about a day and a half
so first i'd like to present some early
proof of concept data that we generated
using our meta transcriptomic kit
that depletes
a human ribosomal but that ribosomal is
designed for mouse and rat as well
plus pan bacterial ribosomal and this
was early data that we generated that
helped us to understand the path forward
for a universal infectious disease assay
as mentioned here this is on clinical
fecal samples that we worked on this
with and so
when we take a look at the y-axis what
we're looking at here is
three fecal samples with and without
depletion and then looking at the
percentage of ribosomal rna that's
remaining in those samples with and
without depletion after sequencing the
y-axis shows this where when we have a
control sample that's non-depleted um
of course the total ribosomal species in
a stacked bar plot it's going to make up
100 of the of the ribosomal species but
then after depletion you can see in each
of these samples we're reducing the
ribosomal content to below ten percent
and in some cases below five percent in
these three sample types and so we're
seeing efficient removal of bacteria and
human ribosomal rna and that includes
gram-positive and gram-negative
bacterial samples
and as i mentioned these were this was
processed these the samples processed
were clinical human stool samples
and next we wanted to take a look at
okay if we've now taken and removed
these fragments from a library
and ultimately
these fragments now don't take up real
estate and form clusters on a flow cell
those cause those those those
that area on the flow cell is now
available for
for other informative fragments to to
form clusters and ultimately sequencing
reads
what kind of increase in sensitivity of
detection would we obtain with that
and you can see here that when we take a
fecal sample that's been non-depleted
and uh and and sequence that fecal
sample at least in these these three
samples and then look at the bacterial
species detected shown here on the
y-axis you can see that we're detecting
somewhere around 35 to 40 percent i'm
sorry 35 to 40 30 to 40 species
of bacteria are detected in these
samples
but when we apply the jump code
depletion technology
the crispr clean metatranscriptomics kit
we see that that increases to somewhere
around 130 to 140 bacterial species
detected
and so thus we're gaining a large
increase in detection three to four-fold
increase in the number of bacterial
species identified with with the crispr
clean tech
in these in these early experiments and
so
uh what this essentially equates to is
an increase in sensitivity of detection
of the bacterial species in these
samples and so
thus
gave us the um
you know gave us the drive to continue
to move forward and development and take
a look at what we might be able to do
with
uh with human samples with uh with
covid's vicon so the next
short slide of data i'm going to show
you is some proof of concept experiments
that we performed using a contrived
sample
that has a covid spike ends
titrated
and so there's a lot of information here
and i'll walk you through this so
essentially
we did a titration um or sorry a a
coveted spike in titration where we went
from one percent spike in into total rna
to .0001 percent
and that's um the percentage fraction
against the total so we took one
nanogram of total rna lung
and we spiked in staph aureus and cova2
the wuhan strain from twist biosciences
and then in the upper left-hand graph
what we're simply looking at here is
we're simply looking at the raw read
alignments to
the
staph aureus genome and the cova genome
with and without depletion
and see you can see here that um
without depletion we have about 20 000
reads or so aligning to that um aligning
to
aligning to those two genomes and we
have a certain proportion of genomes as
well that we're seeing for that
alignment
and then when we uh then look at the
post depletion you can see that that
goes up
considerably to over 180 000 raw reads
and so we're gaining a large fold
increase here in reeds that are aligning
raw reads that are aligning to that to
those two genomes and in fact if you
look at the
the ratio it's more of a qualitative
measure here but you can see the ratio
of staph aureus
to covid
rna in the samples
is retained through the depletion
procedure so there's some uh
you know an unbiased methodology that's
happening in the right hand uh graph
you can see that
of course as we decrease the
as we decrease the
the um the titration of the covid um the
covid control into the sample and we
compare the fold change
between
the mock to depleted samples you can see
here that
as we decrease of course our fold change
is going down but still even at the
lowest spike in amount at point zero
zero one percent viral fraction we're
still retaining
around an eight-fold increase
uh in percentage of read alignments that
are going to the cova genome from mock
to depleted and so based on these
results which are extremely promising
we wanted to move forward to really
build out a full solution for a
universal infectious disease assay
and so next i'm going to start moving
through i'm going to move through
multiple slides of data that shows
that we generated for contrived and
nasopharyngeal sample data so we're
three nasal pharyngeal samples from
covid positive patients
using our crispr clean plus stranded
total rna prep with depleting
human ribosomal rna and pan bacteria as
i mentioned our
ribosomal rna
guide set is designed to human mouse and
rad and also effective on multiple
eukaryotes but
don't want to be confusing here these
are human samples that we're working on
with those two guide sets in our plus
kit
and so a quick note on the technology
before i dive into the data here um
when we think about infectious disease
surveillance and and and certainly the
data that i'm going to show you here and
the methods that we're employing to
generate this data
we don't think about infectious
disease this infectious disease
depletion technology as a replacement to
amplicon sequencing or
qpcr for simply coveted detection
um
our technology is really meant for when
you want to know more or take a deep
dive into a subset of let's say a subset
of positive samples
um maybe even higher ct value positive
samples for the potential of cts that
show up as negative but still the person
has some
um has some
you know showing a sickness and so in
this case
you'd want to be able to take a look at
things like co-infection or typing of
the viruses
even human host response signals
and and potentially unknown pathogens
so
these are the areas that we believe
shotgun metagenomics
paired with
the jump code crispr clean technology
really takes on its real value is
wanting to do a deep dive into what
these samples have in them and being
able to look at multi multiple
compartments of information and so
that's the data that i'm going to show
here
so first just the basic study design
we have three nasopharyngeal covid
positive samples uh these were uh a ct
of 19 26 and 30 and i'll show that on
each of the slides so we have a a high
viral titer an obvious positive a medium
viral titer and a low viral titer
which in some cases under certain assays
may have been called a negative
and then we applied the crispr cream
plus depletion with the
hmr
ribosomal rna and pan bacterial
ribosomal rna guide sets we also
performed a mock depletion control for
each of these samples
and then they were sequenced on a nexseq
2000 at 2 by 100 base pair reads i'll
mention later that we down sampled those
to 28 million reads per sample the
lowest number of reads for any of the
samples we down sampled every every
sample to that
and then we analyze the data
to
uh with multiple pipelines in order to
understand composition of the samples
through id seek
the strain typing using easy biome
and also the using in-house custom
pipelines for genome depth and breadth
of coverage as well as the ribosomal rna
depletion rate and i'm going to show you
data today that covers each of these
each of these types of analysis and i'll
mention and point out each of these as
we move through and what pipeline was
used
so first using our in-house pipelines to
understand rates of depletion for
ribosomal rna
with our contrived sample
which essentially was made up of 50
human rna
50
bacterial rna and a 0.1 percent coveted
spike in
you can see here that the mock sample
that the ribosomal rna originating from
human is approximately 75 percent in the
orange bar and that's the y-axis is is
the percent of total uh percent of total
rna
and then uh the percent of ribosomal rna
coming from bacterial is approximately
25 in the mock sample when we use just
the bacterial guide step to deplete this
sample you can see that we completely
obliterate the bacterial ribosomal rna
and
and the component that that percentage
of that component now is less than five
percent in the total
conversely if we use the human guide set
only
to perform depletion on this sample we
then completely obliterate the human
ribosomal rna and thus
that um to less than five percent and
thus um
reducing that compartment down
and so as you can see here from the
graph on the left
uh both of these guide sets work very
very well and efficiently individually
and then when we mix them together we
would expect the same results and that's
shown here on the right where we're
simply now looking at just the percent
of rna ribosomal rna depletion from
either human or bacterial when we mix
the guide sets together and we're using
those or sorry using those guide sets at
the same time in the in the using those
guide sets on the same samples
you can see that in the mock we have and
uh in sample 370 and 404 we have
approximately 85 percent ribosomal rna
total prior to depletion in the 396 we
have around 60
and then after depletion we're seeing
less than 10 percent across all three of
those samples when we deplete the human
ribosomal and bacterial ribosomal and i
remind you that with this result
what the effect of this is is that now
we essentially are have the ability to
take all of these reads that previously
75 of these reads that previously would
have been
soaked up by ribosomal fragments and we
can now reassign those reads
to an informative portion of this
microbiome sample or nasopharyngeal
sample
for us to better understand what the
components are in there
what the host response is
what other pathogens may be present and
also to be able to strain type the covid
in these covid positive samples
and so first let's talk about
composition of the samples
what we've done here is we took a mock
depleted sample i'm sorry a mock sample
for each of the three so we have our
high ct
to low ct from left to right
respectively here and what we did is we
took the mock sample for each of these
three
we then defined the top ten organisms
based on reads per million
using idc
reads per million is on the y-axis here
and then we simply looked in the
depleted sample and said for these same
organisms
that made up the top 10 in the mock how
many reads per million do we have of
those and then we can develop a fold
change for reads per million between
mock and depleted
and
i'll
just make a blanket statement across all
of these samples for them for for this
range of ct values we're seeing anywhere
between four to ten plus fold
average increase in
fold cov fold reads per million going to
the top 10 organisms in these samples
and just as a sanity check wanted to
take a look here at some of the the
composition of these several of these
organisms in the top ten and when we
take a look at malassezia
uh it's one of the most abundant species
of the human skin microbiota and we see
it in all three of these samples
also when we look at cutting bacterium
acnes you can see that this was also
seen in all three of the samples and
it's it is also a part of the commensal
floor of the skin and can be found in
the mucosa of the nose so these are
nasopharyngeal samples
um not surprising that we're seeing
these in the top ten organisms uh from a
reads per million standpoint but also
good that we're seeing these in the top
10 organisms so this is checking out
here
what's interesting though is then when
we look at the reads per million for
covid in these samples the mock sample
prior to depletion actually did not show
covid
uh based on a reads per million in the
top 10 organisms in that sample very low
viral titer at a ct of 30.
30 plus
but then when we look at the middle ct
and the and the low ct samples we can
see that cova now starts to show up in
those top 10 organisms and in fact in
the middle sample
when in in the markets showing up as as
number four and then when we deplete
that sample we get a tenfold increase in
reads per million that's going to
the
uh kovagino
and we're seeing about a two and a half
two uh two and a half or threefold
somewhere between two and a half and
threefold increase in
um reads per million to the cova genome
and even the low ct or high viral titer
sample
um
so uh
these are very interesting results in
the sense that we have the ability using
this technology and shotgun metagenomics
to go in in a unbiased and also
hypothesis neutral way start to look at
what the compositions of these samples
are while also being able to obtain
the um designation of the cova genome
i also mentioned that you know there's
the potential of
of unknown pathogen identification and
in sample number two you can see here
that we've identified staph aureus and
in fact in the depleted sample we're
gaining tenfold
increase in our and reads per million to
the staph aureus genome
and as we know staph aureus it's it's a
usual member of the microbiota of the
body it's frequently found in the upper
respiratory tract but
it can cause respiratory infections
and so if someone were to potentially
present with
um with
with a
fever or other um types of of
problems or sickness
um that could be potentially thought of
as covid um but in this case um it might
have been found that it could have been
due to staph aureus obviously this is a
coveted positive sample but i'm just
trying to uh to
define an example here where um because
we're able to identify
um the other organisms in these samples
this is a very good way to be able to
uncover co-infection
organisms or unknown pathogens
and now let's focus our attention away
from the
from the
composition to
to actually the cova genomes so this is
in the contrived sample where we have
spiked in
the uh sars cova2 control
from twist at 1.1 percent of the total
rna and you can see
this is simply meant to show the delta
between
untreated to
depleted using the crispr clean plus
kit
you can see here in the mock the genome
coverage is in orange it's
not very easily identifiable and very
low
if we were to just deplete the human
ribosomal rna
such as a product that's currently on
the market now we see an increase in
coverage
but when we use the jump code crispr
clean plus kit you can see that we take
we have an enormous increase in coverage
over the cova genome a ten-fold increase
in uh sars cover two genome coverage in
this contrived sample enough
uh simply an increase in sensitivity of
detection of the kova genome and also
an increase in base pair coverage of the
kova genome which allows one to call
variants in the genome and thus to
perform strain typing
then when we look at the nasopharyngeal
covet positive samples from the three
patient samples with
same thing here ct high ct on the left
to low ct on the right
so
it would be low viral tighter to high
viral tighter respectively
you can see here we're not only looking
at the average depth of coverage per
base that's shown on the y-axis
over the cova genomes between a mock and
depleted sample but we're also showing
the breadth of coverage and that's seen
at the top of each graph next to the
legend um designated by the letter
capital b
and so you can see here that in the
low or sorry the high ct
sample on the left that um with no
depletion uh simple just simply just
shotgun sequencing the average coverage
is approximately
0.12
and so
the
whereas with depletion the average
coverage is point or sorry 1.985
and this represents us around a 16x
increase in coverage over the cova
genome with depletion even at a ct of 30
plus
and
concomitantly with the
the genome we can see that in the mock
we have a nine percent breadth of
coverage of the genome
at 1x cover 1x cov sorry 1x coverage or
greater and then when we
deplete that sample
that breadth of coverage of the genome
at 1x coverage or greater increases to
93 and this represents a 10.3x increase
of brexit breadth of coverage of the
genome
so with a mock sample here um at a ct of
30 plus you can see that that um
depending on the sample number and what
the low level of noise might be of of
alignment to the cova genome
uh an average coverage of 0.12 could
could potentially be in the in noise
but certainly
with an average coverage of 1.9 and a
breadth of coverage of the covert genome
of 93
even at a ct of 30.38 this would not be
in the level of noise and and would
could be seen as a positive
uh the same topology and increase is
seen
across the range of cts and
one of the greatest ones that we see is
in the in sample 404
where we're seeing a 10x coverage in um
in coverage or sorry coverage depth
between the mock and depleted where
we're going from a 1.7 to a 15.5 average
coverage per base
between mock and depleted so a large
general increase across the coverage
genome here
just as an orthogonal validation we
wanted to look at
we wanted to look at and sorry let me go
back here
there we go
we want to look at these same types of
coverages in the using the id seek
analysis platform
the previous graphs were shown using our
in-house custom
analysis platforms but using the idc
we're seeing much of the same
same type of information show up with
sample 370 here we're seeing a we're
seeing an increase in coverage depth
from 0.2 x to 2.2 x this is at a depth
of coverage of 10x or greater
and so we need we're requiring 10 reads
overlapping a base to count this as
covered or not and so we're seeing a
10-fold increase in coverage there and
then
a breadth of coverage at 10x or greater
moving from 11.7
percent in the mock to 42.4 percent and
depleted
and then um
same type of movement here as we uh move
to the middle sample of sample four zero
four um one point seven x to thirteen pi
13.5 x increase in average coverage at
ten x and a seventy one point seven to
ninety nine point four percent increase
in breadth of coverage
so as i mentioned before a universal
infectious disease assay be great to be
able to understand composition of the
sample i've shown you data on that
understanding of of um coverage of the
cova genome in this case since these are
covered positive nasopharyngeal samples
we've looked at that
also
understanding the strain type of the
cova genome and here's data i'm sorry
keep pushing the wrong button here we're
showing data for variant detection of uh
from these clinical samples with a ct of
um the middle and the low cts we're able
to define the variant in those
in the low ct we see a predominance of
the netherlands variant there and in the
high in the in the middle ct
predominance the u.s variant there
the easy biome variant detection
algorithm so this is data using easy
biome as i mentioned before it uses
single nucleotide variant single
nucleotide variants in the alignments
and sample 370 simply did not have
enough in there to pass the filter
however we're continuing to improve our
methodology and
increase the sequencing depth slightly
from 28 million reads and we fully
expect that we'll be able to detect the
variance and the single nucleotide the
variant of that covid genome and the
single nucleotide variance
in that sample in the future
and then finally
the
host response and so what we simply done
here is we're looking at human gene read
counts for these nasopharyngeal samples
and we've cut off noise at 100
at 100
uh reads here and or 100 reads for sorry
we've cut off cut off our counts here at
a hundred so that's why the x and y axis
um the the beginning um number is at 100
but ultimately
we wanted to take a look at the
linearity of the signals between mock
and depleted samples in the
human transcriptome or the host genes in
these samples and you can see here that
the linearity of human gene expression
is retained with depletion for the for
the medium and the low viral tighter
samples
essentially the high viral titer sample
had so much virus in it uh that it it
took up quite a bit of the total rna
space in there and thus um the
sequencing for for the human the human
transcriptome here is essentially a low
input rna sequencing experiment
and the linearity decreases with these
high viral titers for just the reason
that i mentioned
but ultimately
this information and this linearity
provides potential for future
development around host response
especially in samples that show medium
to low viral titers and those things
around host response could be um
biomarkers around host response and in
response to um
in response to um to treatment or even
in response to severity of infection
and so
in summary
with the crispr clean plus depletion all
non-human species receive around a five
to ten fold increase in reads
the coverage of the sars2 cova genomes
increase across all ct values and the
sensitivity of sequencing is equivalent
to pcr to detect the presence of the
covet pathogen
the discovery and assessment of
co-infection
or primary infection species is
available using this technology
since the
depletion affords a large increase in
sensitivity
and also
the there was an effective variant
detection across or covid variant
detection across a range of viral loads
and so final thoughts is that shotgun
approaches will eventually become the
standard
and they'll they will become an unbiased
tool for infectious disease testing
and our jump code crispr clean depletion
makes shotgun metagenomic sequencing a
viable tool for infectious disease
surveillance and jump code is supporting
this early transition to but to an
unbiased path
sorry to unbiased pathogen detection
so thank you today for uh taking the
time to listen
and
happy to take any questions
thank you john for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live q a portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just use that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
so let's get started it looks like we
already have some great questions coming
in
john
here you are using crispr guides that
target human and bacterial ribosomal
script transcripts could you target
other things as well and how would that
affect the sensitivity of the assay
yeah sure so we absolutely can target we
can actually target any um any
transcript or genomic region um that as
long as um
you know we
uh meet our filtering criteria for
uniqueness and gc content and other
things
but um ultimately
within the within the realm of of a
universal infectious disease assay one
one area is if um
if there's less interest in the host
response or the rna human rna data that
i showed at the end of the presentation
the red xy plots
um then you could go after additional
genes there outside of just the
um the non-coding ribosomal transcripts
you could also go after the
the highly expressed poly a ribosomal
genes as well as the highly expressed
poly and mitochondrial genes probably
make up about 20
of the reeds that we're seeing there
uh and then you could also go after
things like actin
um um gap d h other highly expressed
genes and probably recapture another 50
of the sequencing data to reattribute or
reassign to
um the uh bacterial and viral
compartment
and so
um and what that essentially the effect
of that is in sensitivities that raises
the sensitivity of detection
raises the genome coverage as i've shown
here that when we deplete the ribosomal
we're increasing genome coverage and and
so it's it's um it helps to increase
sensitivity of the assay
thank you so much
again thank our audience for these
questions we have another question
coming in how many crispr guides are you
using and is there an upper limit to the
number that you can use
sure so in this assay we have
approximately 13 and a half thousand
guides that we're using
since we're
designing and targeting to 200 plus
bacterial species that takes up a lot of
guide space
so we have about thirteen and a half
thousand in this assay we've tested
up to
six hundred thousand guides uh within a
a genomic uh depletion
environment where we're trying to
deplete regions non-informative regions
of genomic dna
from
non-human
non-human organisms
and but at this point in time we haven't
really been able to reach what that
limit is
like i said we've tested 600 000 guides
and it works
um effectively and efficiently and uh
and we'll just continue to test and at
some point in time we may find that
upper limit but right now we don't quite
know where that is but 600 000 guys is
um gives us a lot of target space
absolutely thank you so much and i want
to thank you for your presentation today
and for your time john would you like to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience before we
go um i think i'm okay thank you for
asking um and thank you for listening to
the presentation and if you have any if
anyone has any questions for me they can
either
track me down through
the folks here um on the line or um
likely find me
somewhere on the interwebs so
well again i want to thank you for your
time and for your research before we go
i also want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions and i want to
thank jumpco dynamics for sponsoring
today's webinar questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration and this webcast will be
viewed on demand for two years until
september 9 2023
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may miss today's
live event
until next time everyone take care and
stay healthy bye